some breaking news former las vegas  raiders head coach john gruden is suing  the nfl commissioner roger goodell and  others over his departure in his suit  gruden claims as you see on your screen  here this is directly from the lawsuit  through a malicious and orchestrated  campaign the nfl and commissioner roger  goodell sought to destroy the career and  reputation of john gruden the former  head coach of the las vegas raiders of  course gruden left after emails  racially insensitive among other things  emails were released and put in the new  york times so we're going through the  paperwork we'll have more on this on 8  news now on 8newsnow.com